ja du musst jetzt auch kopfhörer hören
war wird schwer
so mache sieht man wie hallo leute
wenn ich laut mensch timo ich habe auch
es wir spielen haben wir das sogar
pünktlich geschafft 15 jünger ja ich
habe meine palme dass nur der staat
hallo leute ich will jetzt stream
aber ich möchte es mal ein bisschen nach
machen kommt man also wer der timo haid
ihm doch siehst du so jung aus in der
kamera sieht echt so aus du bist einfach
credit ausgeht weg du machst mich
hässlich für ansprechende titel
das ist doch das was heute passiert also
bei denen kommt man wenn ich was machst
du das eigentlich genau ich mach zwei
ich mache mich zwei ich mache nur ich
benutze das mal stativ damit ich mich in
ruhe schmecken kann und die leute mich
sehen können darum geht es doch hier ja
du freust dich wieder nadal zählt er dem
fanclub doch das würden kampeter ihr
wusste dieses dings stativ dieses
dreibein
mal leute ich finde es super wie die
leute gleich mit fragen anfangen
entspannt euch mal diese leute dort wird
hier noch alles ganz verrückt hey wir
haben gerade kurieren barbecue gegessen
und guckt man meiner in story da könnt
ihr das sehen
also das ist natürlich jetzt scheiße
dass die inzwischen angefangen habe
bevor ich überhaupt hier alles
eingerichtet habe aber ganz ehrlich ich
nehme auch keine spenden und könntest
den hintergrund den fernseher so ein
bisschen an leuchten weil dann aber wenn
du so sieht sie da so ausgeklügelt aus
war nur kurz eine gute idee kannst du
dich grüßen
ich habe irgendwann nicht verstanden in
dem ein video hast du timo zensiert und
mittendrin aufgehört zu zensieren
du hast mir ziehen sie damit in der
regel die ganze zeit sind wir bis
ziemlich gleich weiter
man ist doch alles wieder hier sein
gefummel leute hey wie gehts euch
ok jetzt ist dass die bubiker auch das
wird nix wie ist es ja doch doch das ist
doch cool so kann man's machen
ok also die mode muss jetzt aber
wirklich kopfhörer benutzen
1 ab nächstes jahr ist es ja so dass ich
ein neues büro ziel dann sind jemand ich
nicht mehr in einem zimmer wir sind
jetzt auch nicht so lange in einem
zimmer gewesen sondern nur einen monat
jetzt sieht man nicht auch von ich
wollte ich doch so ein bisschen in ruhe
lassen dass du nicht ganz an dem stream
sein muss ach so ja das ist natürlich
schlauer die fitmacher team julian
julian ich habe einfach die gleiche
bluse ja das ist die schönste bluse die
habe ich von borouge 3 komplett die bahn
ja ich hab drei kommt jetzt die ballade
auch im petto ich hatte so gar keine
zeit jetzt das zuschneiden das tut mir
auch ehrlich gesagt leid erwartet ist
ein kimono an
das wird eine bluse in der css so ich
muss mich ja gleich schminken wenn man
hier so dann seht ihr was ich tue
ok ich brauche meine kopfhörer und ich
brauch musik wir können aber nicht links
neben ihm bestimmt hatte damit so eine
silvester playlist wette ich mit euch
mit mir sieg
as oslo zeit wäre auch mal wieder
angebracht
sonst mit dem kompliziert ich hab gerade
aufgestoßen hört ihr mit ihr hat mich
befinde
also wir gehen heute abend zu freunden
und werden dort silvester feiern und ich
glaube es wird sehr schön und auch mal
entspannter und ruhiger weil wir haben
jetzt echt die letzten jahre immer so
abende gehabt an silvester wo wir auf
einer party angefangen haben dann sind
wir weiter gelaufen dann ist es die
nächste bar die nächste party
irgendwie ist man niemals so zur ruhe
gekommen hat man richtig gefeiert
dieses mal machen wir es anders dieses
mal mit richtig das sollte nicht kippen
bis heute nicht weiß ich warum ich das
gemacht habe
dieses mal mit richtig entspannt
gefeiert das wollte ich sagen und das
mikro muss noch irgendwie so eigentlich
habe ich gedacht also ich hier
wir könnten zwei sachen machen
einerseits könnte ich nicht sinken
aber ich dachte auch eigentlich wäre es
auch ganz cool wenn wir mal so auf
meinen kanal gucken und wieso man die
videos durchgehend die gekommen sind und
wie immer und immer wieder das angucken
aber das ist die frage worauf wir lust
schminken eigentlich mal ganz geil
ganzheitlich zu schminken
was ist an silvester wir haben jetzt
gerade also in meiner in story könnt ihr
das sehen
an silvester haben wir dieses mal
kurieren barbecue gemacht weil ich das
kino zu weihnachten geschenkt habt und
das heißt screen barbecue gewesen mit so
hot pot an der seite das heißt man
konnte seiner seite so eine suppe essen
und obendrauf sich so fleisch braten und
das dann halt in salat welle machen und
sich den mund schieben was ich ja seit
diesem jahr seit wir new york waren
extrem liebe und sonst haben wir mal
raclette gemacht aber raclette ist ganz
ehrlich so glatt ist sonst echt du hast
auf den magen schminken
schminken schmecken ja sorry leute dann
wird das schminken lässt tatsächlich
mehr schminken
ich kenne auch beides machen aber ich
glaube ich nicht kann das nicht so gut
kombinieren sagen wir mal hier silvester
musik best of ferdinand in japan heißt
es auch so im englischen sagt man da
auch silvester ja news.ch receivers
hat dir was ich muss mir meine kopfhörer
hören holen und klett video video wie
hier sagen ja ist videos beides wir
machen beides kommt ist ja in
entspannter streep ich hoffe ihr habt
heute nicht zum stressigen abend und
könnt euch entspannt fertigmachen und
losgehen weil du das gefühl man
silvester mannschaft und den ganzen tag
weil es irgendwie nicht so ein richtiger
tag ist erzählt nicht so als nicht so
dass man so einen freien tag hat oder so
also man muss ja irgendwo hin ist ja ich
meine dieser jahreswechsel der erste
erstes nicht so ein richtiger tag wenn
man einfach nur kaputt ist und das ist
uns silvester ist nicht so ein richtiger
tag
ich habe heute die fingernägel machen
das ist ein sicheres tor passiert ist
und ich war beim asia man damit wir
wirklich politik machen können
als reformer südkorea zu besuchen jahren
dieses jahr wäre schon mega also ich
möchte das sind also wenn es nächstes
jahr klappt jetzt super es mussten nicht
dieses jahr klappen aber das wäre schon
haben wir schon sagen
schöne grüße aus ja das ist ja geil war
das eigentlich nichts die leute schwingt
euch doch selbst ihr könnt euch ja
eigentlich auch so machte paktes handy
das mache ich immer so wenn ich mich
schminken muss schaue ich irgend so ein
extrem langes video an
weil das immer so unglaublich lange
dauert und ja wir in einer gesellschaft
leben in der bekennende durch irgendwas
haben
ich bin noch dabei mein zimmer
aufzuräumen spark das ist halt auch so
eine beschäftigung die man silvester
sicher richtig an gewöhnen kann damit
einfach an silvester sein zimmer oder
seine wohnung zu kontinent aufräumt
damit mandanten ersten ersten auf steht
schon das gefühl hat es wird ein gutes
jahr
ich werde meine vorsätze einheiten oder
wenn man keine hat ich werde einfach
nicht verpacken
wenn man in so einem unaufgeräumten
wechseln ich habe das heute morgen nicht
gewusst ist viel besser ist ja das ist
auch natürlich gut
ich finde generell die zeit zwischen
weihnachten und neujahr komisch ja danke
und ich glaube das findet jeder und wir
müssen irgendwann mal anfangen irgendwas
in diese zeit einzubauen dass man sagt
das ist die zeit in der man alles in der
wohnung repariert oder das ist die zeit
und den klima und macht eine scheiße tag
nur halt musst deine scheiße woche aber
immerhin bin aber man also wir waren
jetzt auch bis sonntag waren wir bei
teams familie im süden deutschlands und
da sind wir auch so nach weihnachten saß
mir da noch so jungen mann soll jetzt
können wir auch viel besser feiern
also ich hoffe auf jeden fall hatte ein
schönes weihnachten das tut mir extrem
leid dass ich klopfe ist einfach
abgebrochen habe aber ich habe gemerkt
wenn ich noch weiter gemacht hätte hätte
es an meiner gesundheitlichen friede
freude eierkuchen einstellung gezerrt
und deswegen dachte ich nein einfach
aufhören die leute sind nicht böse
das sind nette menschen die deine videos
schauen sie werden verstehen und war ja
auch so aber ihr habt viel nachgefragt
nur fand er nicht den rhythmus kommt und
ich habe auch überlegt ob ich dann bei
nacht als ich habe auch so ein bisschen
noch versucht zu blocken
aber ich habe gemerkt das hat irgendwie
immer meine stimmung runter gemacht wenn
wir da irgendwo saß und ich da irgendwie
dachte okay jetzt hole ich meine kamera
aus und jetzt muss ich das auch film das
hat dann immer sogleich irgendwie alles
kaputt gemacht und ihr wisst ja selber
wie das ist wenn man loggt ihr kennt das
alle
das ist ein absoluter muss noch essen
vorbereiten dann schminken was du zu
weihnachten bekommen
ich hab s bahnen scheine
ganz viele küchen zeug ohne neue kette
habe ich bekommen meine allerliebsten
schwiegermutter hat gerade zum schauen
und ich habe das mädchen die kette
stelle mir das und noch mal stressig vor
jeden tag ein video rauszuhauen
tatsächlich ging das volk hätte ich mich
nicht so sehr gestresst habe was den
content angeht aber doch also nach zwei
wochen reicht gemerkt so urig mal einen
tag pause der mensch braucht dann schon
mal pause werde ich wahrscheinlich auch
nicht mehr so schatten
außer ich mir irgendwann katar haben
dann wird vielleicht andere sachen
möglich sein
hier könnt ihr euch ja
was hab ich zu weihnachten verschenkt
ich habe timo eincremen barbecue sap
geschenkt und bilder
ich hab nur bilder torleute ist was
sogleich und jetzt wollte ich eigentlich
auch stream weil ich dachte das wäre
voll cool zuzuschauen
welche bilder gemalt und zwar für jeden
der der familie also der bei uns mit
gefeiert habe ich so ein personal also
die schwester zum beispiel war schwan
büro für ein jahr
und dann habe ich da so den regenbogen
mountain somit spachteltechnik nur
gemalt und wir haben die bilder auch
echt alle gut gefallen hätte sie auch
gerne irgendwie bei mir selber
aufgehalten aber natürlich war das
geschenk und die leute an sich glaube
ich sehr gefreut oder meine bilder kamen
gut an
ja ja
vielleicht eine unpassende frage wo bist
du religiös wenn man sowas fragen kann
dann doch zur silvester neues zeit
ich bin schwierig also ich wurde
katholisch erzogen würde mich aber heute
nicht als katholik sehen und auch nicht
so richtig als christ obwohl ich das als
kind total geil fand das mega als kind
so die kirche gehen und an den gott
glauben und geht es für uns gestorben
damit wir unsere sünden war war war fand
ich auch glaube ich bin also ich glaube
kinder schadet religionen ich wenn sie
nicht zu extremen ist alles immer extrem
ist schlimm es schadet kindern auch
nicht wenn sie hinter glas kriegen wenn
sie fertig ist das mein aber also als
kind fand ich cool da hat das gibt einem
so ein halt so na ja der liebe gott pass
auf uns auf abwegen passiert und allen
nichts und meinen robert gestorben hätte
sie gerade aus ja aber wenn man dann
wachsen wird merkt man so jo warum zahle
ich eine kirchensteuer
was machen die außerirdische kirchen mit
goldblatt dekorieren
[Musik]
wann machst du nochmal wie schmeckt wie
schmeckt wird jetzt im neuen jahr mit
dem neuen büro sagt das wird alles noch
mal eine ganze ecke besser besser
organisiert regelmäßiger die guten
formate kommen alle wieder
und das ist mein pony das ist und in
2020 die das pony wieder weg also an
alle die das pony nicht mochten hurra
und die dies machten dazu bereit
verabschiedet euch das wird jetzt raus
fraktionen ea vanessa paradis heute
feuerwerke ja ich liebe also früher wie
das geliebte raketen steigen zu lassen
und so aber jetzt bin ich schon gestern
oder so sind wir glaube ich noch mal
einkaufen gegangen zu fuß weil gute
nachhaltige menschen sind und da lag
dann schon so plastikverpackung
förmlichen raketen und danach dieser
habe nur knallerbsen geholt den
biologisch besser auf jeden fall
datenträger viel erreicht dann jetzt
auch mal wir werden ja eh anderes
feuerwerk angucken können und ganz gut
brauchen wir jetzt nicht mehr
oder es geht ja nicht nur ein pflaster
es geht darum dass er müll einfach in
die luft geschossen wird und in
irgendeinem teich gelandet ist halt
nicht geil und ich weiß dass leute dann
immer so auf die die wollen immer so auf
diese tradition zurückgreifen und sagen
ja da haben wir das schon im land
gemacht und ich leben das becken lassen
und ich kann das ja verstehen die fühlen
sich dann so angegriffen so alles was
mir spaß macht wollte mir wegnehmen
aber man muss halt auch einfach
kompromisse eingehen können
und wenn es schon ist okay wir holen
dieses mal nicht den super laser 36.000
schuss und irgendwie drei phasen sondern
ich wohl einfach mal eine raketen
packung reicht heißt ich habe auch in
zeitungen oder so ich gesehen dass in
der zeit wer sagt denn heutzutage noch
mehr zeit ich habe in der zeitung
gelesen die belag das also da wohnen so
leute gezeigt die so extrem viel für
silvesterknaller ausgeben
die haben einfach teilweise 500 euro so
eine familie gibt einfach jedes jahr 500
euro für silvesterknaller aus polnischer
eltern ihre dann gesagt haben nimm nicht
so viel kaufen du kannst einfach beiden
nachbarn gucken die machen auch
wir dürfen in österreich keine
feuerwerke schießen nur die feuerwehr
darf es aber ich mache es trotzdem
[Musik]
das ist nicht synchron deine stimme zum
video
ich glaube das liegt dann nur in die
weil sonst sehen dass alle schreiben
na ja ich glaube schon
also ich habe vor dass timo nächstes
jahr stream via stream soll er machen
will kommt ja nächstes jahr hinweg
morgen media streams teams nämlich jetzt
ein via profi geworden
guck mal das ist echt besser wenn du mit
deinem weißen dastehst brauchen
background wenn du dann mit einem weißen
stehst und ist das bild voll schön und
wenn du dann weg gehst weil dann ist
dunkel im hintergrund ist dann ist das
nicht so schön haben wir irgendwas was
ich hinten aufhängt anlegen
den stein
seine eben darum das ist ein ratloses
angegangen den wind seid ihr eigentlich
die print sowie bei der brille - 2 wir
können tatsächlich die brille vom
anderen relativ gut tragen weil wir so
ein tolles pärchen sind uns zu sehr
lieben haben sich unsere augen
aufeinander abgestimmt so läuft es ja
wir sind seelenverwandt
du brauchst ein background jakobus auf
werden wenn du machst du hast im berufs
noch über weggelobt
das ist alles noch mal aufs nächste
level ja da kann ich nicht das internet
ist doch draußen background nimmt sein
speck war ich wollte ein weiter weg
das kann ich nicht kommst du nach cape
mit carina stuttgart ich war gerade in
stuttgart
ok also leute ich der zweite teil mit
wein nils ja leute der kommt niemals im
leben
ich werde ihn vielleicht mal in dem
stream das ist gegessen geschichte das
ist ich habe das habe ich schon im
letzten streamer gesagt das ist das
problem ist bei diesem video
das ist palin die erstes zu schneiden
weil und es ist nicht so dass ich mir
für mich für arbeit drücken möchte
es sind sechs leute und ich habe es nach
drei stunden nicht geschafft seinen
schnitt reinzukriegen das ist keineswegs
so wirkt als ob man mitbekommt was
passiert man kriegt also die brille von
timos neue oder sieht aus wie verhelfen
nein die muss brille ist alt er hatte
nämlich eine neue dass man die
durchsichtige und hatte sein alter und
zum mama sein alter aufgezogen waren ihr
wieder nach koh back in time wenn sie
runter
unser museum wieder fixieren
schauspielerin
weiter ist eine der mega fertig hier
wollen wir ran kommen ich sie irgendwie
jetzt aus wie ich also ein feature so
die sekretärin oder karla kolumna aber
die rasende reporterin und du sie aus
wie harry potter steht ja das ist auch
die der papa von harry potter
ich mag herausforderungen
kennst du okay leute ich will jetzt mein
make-up dann weil ich man muss anfang
ich bin gleich wieder da ich kann die
musik gerne lauda machen weil sie wollte
ich nicht da bin werden
[Musik]
da
entlassen
[Musik]
links
wir wollen
[Musik]
sorry ist wie richtig case denn dieser
song heißt face to face ich könnte auch
so eine radiosendung machen
also ich hatte glück mein ganzes make up
ist nämlich noch zusammengepackt und
eine spende leuchtet hier noch gut kann
es echt praktisch dieses scheiß denkmal
ist einfach nur so licht
ich sage euch wirklich
bizerba ist das geilste spiel der welt
und wieder ist sowieso mega grassl
tierleid kalkulieren kommentar die musik
fast genauso aus wie ein sportlehrer wow
also leute zu meinem silvester lockt ihr
werdet es immer einen richtigen krassen
zu westerlo ziehen
ich benutze ich kann da ich mal auch
wirklich ankommen und ich über mich
selbst
ich benutze die shane dawson conspiracy
pellet hier hat sie tolle aufmacht dinge
und dann macht man sie auf und tat hat
hat oder seid ihr schön oder tolle
farben in dieser scharf stellen würde
ich glaube jetzt echten komischen
schönheitsfehler drauf ich muss mal
gucken dass wir jetzt zu wissen wer
macht sich auch gerade ready ja macht
euch mal die leute ich muss sagen ich
war gestern bei einer gesichtsreinigung
ich sage euch nicht einladen weil ich
will ihnen nicht schlecht machen er ist
ein bruder laden aber die hat mir so
alles gemacht und dann habe ich so
gesagt ja können sie vielleicht so die
härchen hier so ein bisschen bezog wachs
oder so hat man dann hat sie da so
drumherum gefror welt und so aggressiv
und sie hat auch nicht gesagt ist es so
anspannen soll oder so ist sie halt
einfach gemacht und seit gestern fühlt
sich das so weiß ich nicht so
angeschwollen an und so empfindlich und
richtig henry aggressiv also ich kenne
mich gerade wieder
eine kameraeinstellung das video
konfiguration strike hintergrund
weißabgleich hintergrund verstärkung
[Musik]
kamerasteuerung ich aber nicht
kir
aber wenn kein juli führt auf meine
kamera einfach nicht mit obwohl oder was
so sorry ich lese und das mitbringen
ich könnte noch versuchen näher zu
kommen
aber das wird echt peinlich aussehen
jetzt in welchem hocker zu hause bist du
natürlich bin ich hier in gräfendorf
nicht mal alle anderen blödsinn sondern
weil also ich habe einfach nur mutiges
herz
jetzt hab ich kein youtube kanal ist
logisch oder
ok also könnte ich
die mich meine augen zusammen
ich glaube ich hab mir nehme ich meine
kamera zugeschnitten
eigentlich
also was macht ihr silvester
du siehst aus wie ein maulwurf ohne
brille ja eigentlich geht dann bei uns
noch mal ganz gut habe ich die nicht mir
irgendwie sicher dass ich sie mal
zugeschnitten habe jetzt endlich wieder
wie man das machen was transformation
die müsste doch eigentlich
komisch zu groß ich frage mich gerade
also ich finde mich gerade dass das so
[Musik]
irgendwie so ein komisches format hat
ich sehe ich aus wie ich fühle mich auch
gerade absolut wie ein 0 0
ich weiß nicht mehr wo ich das
zuzustimmen habe jetzt könnte er sich
nicht sein dass ich eigentlich noch mehr
kamera zur auswahl hätte dem projekt
vorstellen
machst du noch was spannendes ja ich
mache jetzt ich fühle mich mal das ist
immer sollte ob so meine eltern anfangen
würden so m machst du jetzt noch was
oder
also falls ich mal zugeschnitten habe
dann hab ich jetzt doch keine ahnung
bietet zurück mache ich mir auch okay
aber erstmal die augen reiben würden wir
euch schminken wollen und das ganze crew
in barbecue schön ins gesicht einreiben
was wollt ihr euch nämlich behalten so
mein eindruck miracoli web schlechter
tipp okay mein name ist hier nicht sehen
so ich benutze das passt doch perfekt
ich benutze den depeschen um erstmal
alles leben in mir auszulöschen jeden
fehler und man sieht sogar ein bisschen
oder das spachtelt ihr einfach so in
eurer haut
da waren wir gestern bei der
gesichtsreinigung können wir heute alles
wieder zu machen ich dachte ich starte
nämlich so mein oder ende mein jahr
richtig in dem zur gesichtsreinigung
gehe und meine fingernägel machen lassen
mit den fingernägeln bin ich super
zufrieden mit der gesichtsreinigung
nicht so also dass
ihr wollt auch so kleine pickelchen
bekommen jetzt
und ich sehe uns da gerade was kohls
es sieht aus als habe ich mich so dass
ich meine wahl sieht nicht so gut aus
ich hätte oder so und hier sitzen
bewegung es ist aber anscheinend auch
normal dass man zu einer
gesichtsreinigung ich hasse es silvester
war ich immer alleine bin meine faschist
und und zwei freunde ich habe niemanden
leuten war hier seien leute ihr könnt
immer mit euren verwandten feiern
ich habe jedes jahr besser mit meiner
freundin gefeiert es war auf jetzt nicht
krisenfest aber sagen ich uns schön so
als nächstes benutze ich fand ihn
endlich sehen meine fingernägel wieder
so ausschüssen sie zu euch zeigen kann
die bringer
wenn ich rausgehen und sich das manchmal
wenn ich nur so und so also ich schminke
mich zum 10
wenn ich jeden tag habe ich filme oder
so dann hätte sich so ein anderes ganz
dünnes aber wenn ich wie heute abend
draußen sein muss und so dann ein
richtiges schicht und make-up drauf ganz
schön mein gesicht schützen austrocknen
nicht so sicher make up fleck auf der
unterlippe
ich möchte auf jeden fall super damit
auch mit meinen vielen punkten
als ihm eine schmink video gesehen habe
ist ja das wichtigste
ja und das ist ein mega sieht jetzt
nichts zur bombe aus
das echt auch nicht happy
seit gestern ist mein hobby sauer auf
mich kann ich schon sagen eigentlich die
will mir sagen die besten die haut ist
so vanessa warum hast du diese fremde
frau heran gelassen die uns einfach
gequält hat
und die hauen komplett ausgetrocknet hat
und was ganz komische haut beratung auch
ich will diesen laden nicht halten ich
will nicht irgendwas ja also wenn das
herpes kriegt eigentlich zum viele
menschen mit herpes bekannten die herpes
irgendwie bekommen weil sie nicht
ich kann einfach nicht gezeigt ich
möchte dass meine 2020 geschenkt mal war
das beauty palace einzel leute jetzt
wisst ihr das alles super verteilen
wirklich verteilt es gut verteilt ist so
lange bis ihr keine streifen
irgendwelche klümpchen und sonst was
sagt und wenn ihr merkt es ihr make-up
drauf tragt und das irgendwie alles
außen des ablaufs eine sahara noch mehr
sand drauf gekippt hätte dann macht es
nochmal runter und fehlt irgendwie
vorsichtig euer gesicht mit irgendwas
mit dieser toten hautschüppchen wechseln
weil dann sind jetzt viel besser aus die
mühe muss man sich dann doch noch und
immer schön den rand hier zwei wenn ihr
das make-up nur bis hier auf fragt die
leute sehen dass wenn jetzt die seite
dreht den indischen hero wenn ich zur
seite redet sie sagen wollte ist wenn
ihr hier mehr auftrag
ihr make-up beauftragt und hier nicht
ist nicht mehr ganz vielen leuten da
könnte ich schon durch drehen aber dann
müsst ihr alter grundsätzlich und nach
unten auslaufen lassen
habt keine angst davor auf euren halt
mit make up to als teenager habe ich
immer gedacht so man macht das hier so
bis zu dem rand und ab hier kommt keiner
aber nur älter bis merkst du du kannst
eigentlich den ganzen körper mit make-up
einschmieren
ich werde heute abend also jemand hat
gesagt ich werde heute abend bei einem
kumpel sein
und der hat eine ganz tolle dachterrasse
und auf den können wir ganz entspannt
oder
und ja dachte ich habe mich ab müssen so
gefordert sind gefragte bekommen möchten
da hast du auch dieses bieten haben das
ist kommt das von deinen pc
ich habe es kommt von deinem pc so leute
mit meiner kurz lippenpflege drauf und
zwar nicht nur für meinen eos
lippenbalsam den ich meinem
adventskalender drin hatte borkmann wenn
ich so nah halterin sie das voll geil
aus ja das kommt auf die lippen in
charlotte plätzen video gesehen hat
jemand so 100 lippenstifte gehabt als er
lippenpflegestifte der bestandspflege
statt fand ich crazy vor allem hatte sie
so jeden dieser bälle also
weil wisst ihr wo von ihr trockener
lippen krieg mit ihr zu wenig wasser
trinkt er kann erlebten kläger nicht
auch wenig helfen einiger wasser trieben
so was machen wir denn als nächstes
machen wir den lidschatten
aber ich mache heute richtig crazy ich
finde es silvester ist so der tag da
kannste richtig ausrasten
dafür machen wir erstmal unsere
lidschatten base drauf damit wir auch
ausrasten können und es auch hält
ich fühle mich darin verpasst
jetzt nicht auch seine oma hat gerade
die sehen nicht so aus wie eine oma und
den augen noch und den augen noch
verblenden ein rallye vor saufenden
justice jeden day
nein das sollte man diese leute trinken
zu bilden
tipps zum winter im wimpern verkleben
das ist auch sehr spannend
ach ich frage mich wurde er drauf stellt
er doch mit david c
nein da wird heute an die ganze zeit
schon aus als ob ich mit meinen lippen
aufgespritzt weil das hier so alles
angeschwollen ist
[Musik]
der konzern mache ich meistens immer
danach drauf ich weiß vielleicht sollte
man den vorher drauf machen aber das
problem ist bei concealer bei
lidschatten
das fällt mir mal alles auf die bank ich
weiss man könnte sich da so tiemann und
so drauf machen und dann muss man also
danach meisten alter schickt mir die
ganze zeit über alex hat mega praktisch
aber nett wenn ich bei der arbeit so ok
also jetzt müssen wir uns mit
lidschatten skeptischen alle müssen
schöne farbe entscheiden
die ausrasten halten
pink machen
wenn ich so mit pink aus raste dann wird
es immer meistens auch noch so
schlechter karneval
[Musik]
ich mache auf jeden fall orange das
schießt das ist wenn ich mir die schöne
kathi screen wieder in rot gelb rot rot
blau lila dies bloß leider nicht so ist
das becken das ist wie so ein weiß er
wenn man es drauf macht das grün ist er
wie so ein schwarzes darauf macht das
geld ist natürlich mega geil aber schaut
euch das mal ich finde nämlich
wenn man das nämlich dann auf die haut
macht das ist dann halt nicht mehr so
leuchtend das ist dann nicht mehr so wie
in der packung so crazy leuchten toxic
das ist dann halt dann so ein grün gelb
oder so ein gelb gelb halt aber es
eigentlich auch schon geil wenn man
davon fielen um dann kann man es ja gut
also dunkel lila rot und gelb rot orange
gelb also vier wir werden rot gelb
orange ich liebe es dass ich in den
livestreams also wirklich immer komplett
mich von euch abhängig mache und einfach
auf eure meinung so viel fax gebe
ok also gefangen man an mit orange gehe
ich mal gut in orange reihen ist das
viel
ach so wundert euch nicht nehmen für die
seiten kommentare dass es timo der via
spiel in wa
ach so wahrt so cool ist viele leute
belastend aus kinder grün lila gold neue
orange grün
ich mache aufstoßen muss unglaublich ist
etwas richtig dekadentes ich habe
letztens davon dass ich champagner gut
vertragen
das bedeutet ich habe erst mal schön
champagner gekauftes über sondern weil
er sechs tage krieg mikrofon schmid mich
auch gerade neben weiß super kommt leute
geschminkt sind also das mache ich jetzt
in die 2
die planungs- bau- ihn einfach geil dass
die farbe schießt das heißt weil man es
drauf macht es für die anbieter teams
lässt
sorry wir gerade voll dass die lobby
die kreise zu erinnern was als nächstes
passiert
warum hat man noch mal ein déjà vu ich
habs gerade vergessen das ist weil das
gehirn irgendwie falsch
das ist doch grass oder aber geil krass
nicht scheiße krass ich bin ein
paradiesvogel
so wie arbeiten wir von hier aus weiter
dass ich meine kinder ist eine gute
frage
schön dass ihr sie gestellt hat jetzt
muss da auf jeden fall was mit rot
passieren
ein bisschen rot auf den finnen
das ist hier nichts anderes als malen
jetzt noch gelb gebe aber hier drauf
aber wenn ich jetzt auch noch rot
benutze und geld dann sieht das auch so
mit den regenbogen meinen wollen würde
der titel eyes frankenhoch jetzt einfach
relativ es aufsitzen sein
er ist halt so und jetzt ist die zeit
man muss halt früher anfangen weil sonst
stresst man sich übels die lahn grün das
moment wenn man einfach zu hause ist
heute abend nicht tut wenn ihr zuhause
dann macht dabei das beste draus
spielten geiles spiel oder so ich hasse
sie das ja zum beispiel ich habe keine
freunde in berlin mit dem wir einfach
meisten spieler am machen können und
also und dann vielleicht noch mal
rausgehen und so sind alles so party
mäuse der nageldesign typ hat mich auch
heute gefragt ob ich ins berghain heute
gehe
mit männern der kamera uhr ja das sieht
man diskret papst eine buy out of the
way we make it like the same sights und
beton systems hat unser also seid habt
ihr denn eigentlich bock wenn ich jetzt
so in das neue büro umziehen so hatte da
eigentlich braucht dass ich das so euch
alles zeige wie ich das aufbau- und
dekoriert und so oder sag dir so eugene
rüber und lasst uns damit in ruhe du
bist du zum arbeiten so alt dass die
züge aus ich sehe nichts kabeln die
skalierbar bin ich glaube leute an die
werfen guter also an mir dass ein bruder
beauty blogger auch verloren gegangen
eigentlich kann ich auch beides machen
ich meine main kanal könnte man ja
sowieso nicht beschreiben als was da so
passiert
ich mache jetzt machen wir live streams
und ich mache mich für silvester ready
ich muss ein bisschen mehr rein kommen
um die kommentare zu lesen es tut mir
leid
mist was habe ich gefragt ja ach so büro
jetzt wieder geil
habt ihr bock ich mache die mit blogs
dann auch wieder recht cool ich konnte
ja zu blocken das zeit konnte ich ja
nicht nur richtig also kohleblock
schneiden
es war ja dann so can run run run run
bloß fertig werden weil am nächsten tag
muss schon der nächste kommen aber wenn
ich so richtig zeit für den schnitt von
seinem blog dann ist das erneuerung
lustig die new york ist zum beispiel
oder dass der auswandern der hat mir gut
gefallen weil ich da so kreativ sein
konnte ja jetzt ist rot dabei vom hier
mein bestes ergebnis 2009/10 war glaube
ich 2009/10 papier das kochbuch kam raus
und alles was damit zu tun hatte dieses
ganze
diese feier dazu also diese release
party dann new york auf jeden fall weil
das das erste mal war dass ich einfach
so kontinent verlassen habe und einfach
weiter als spanien gefahren bin und der
umzug in dieser wohnung der war auch das
war ein schönes erlebnis also auch wenn
dann die panikattacken sie losgegangen
können aber vergessen jetzt mal
wo bleibt saufen den jahren gut leute
bis jetzt ja auch wie ich mich auch
einfach so richtig und hab mich muss man
nicht mehr lange überzeugen zum zum
saufen ding hat denkt gute trinkspiele
ich wollte aber habe ich es auch nicht
wenn man sich mal diese jenga
vorbereiten und so habe ich irgendwo
irgendwann irgendwer hat von euch hat
mir das gezeigt dass sogar so kleine
zettelchen auf die dinger dinger
schreiben oder direkt ein raublinger
dinge schreiben aufgaben die man machen
muss wenn man einen stein zieht
gold aus anna h das damals gold austrieb
daraus macht augenlid gold dann würde
uns vielleicht zu weihnachtlich aussehen
ich habe ein tier noch so zum grün gold
so einen brauchst ich habe dieses moskau
wird gut aussehen
oder halt silva das sind super ich mache
mir jetzt mit diesem lila weiter das
wollten auch leute haben pizza fehlt der
glitzerwelt durch blitze gx meine
glitzer küste
ich liebe auch mittlerweile das einfach
rumlaufen wie so ein paradiesvogel und
nicht das gar nicht juckt also ich find
das heißt soviel oder sagen gefällt ihm
hier war ich mich ganz nicht geschminkt
sein
es liegt dazu weiter ruhig
hier sieht es nicht so gut
[Musik]
schon geschieht nicht also was sich 2020
auf jeden fall ändern wird ist mein
streaming setup weil das wird eine ecke
professioneller und das wird dann alles
viel besser aussehen das verspreche ich
euch jetzt hoch und heilig oder kakao
dieses direkte lichts kommt einfach
nicht darauf klar du bist auch ohne
make-up hübsch das ist sehr nett aber
ich lieb' make up finden paradiesvogel
so ich mache jetzt auf jeden fall schon
mal hier dieses helle glitzer obendrauf
sowie house pop das pop das ballett
leute guckt man guckt mal wie dieser
lidschatten band ich mache einfach
formate 2020 wo alles ballert make up
das ballett
auf jeden fall mehr verbrennt ich bin so
ein blending fascies ich bin hier als
mein blending branche style hat blendet
mir jetzt die schweinfurter aus dem auge
raus
es tut mir leid dass wir ihm ganz
schnell nicht etwas katzen ja und
blenden es doch einfach ich versteh ich
das richtig mit den blättern blenden ist
doch einfach so lange diesen pinsel am
augen reiben ist es so unsere firma
keine geduldeten bin ich so oft
ausgeblendet
weil sie aber nicht ob das schon alles
gewesen sein
alle gut ist sagen wir blenden blenden
blenden blenden das gefühl sich etwas
verpassen club bedient nicht beigetreten
weiters sieht aber auch nicht mehr
gucken da hätte ich vielleicht sogar
auch so machen vielleicht auch einmal
daran sich schon alt werde noch diese
koreanischen es gibt doch so koreanische
operation dass wir seine gesichtshaut so
nach hinten ziehen kannst das ist dem
hinter sich
jetzt muss ein concealer nehmen ich
brauche geld sagt recht die lizenzen das
lila sind jetzt richtig krank aus
also echt nicht so viel wie in der
kamera das sieht schon ein bisschen aus
als ob ich immer fette landon ist doch
genauso seinem zeichnen
er habe ein zeichen habe ich irgendwie
so ein vielseitig verfolgen will nicht
mehr fliegen
das blenden an wo er das
volk rose lee grüße schnedl aber jetzt
noch geld
ich mache es einfach jetzt komplett hier
drauf ich mache mein problem aus ich
glaube aber dass
ich weiß immer noch wie ein kommentar
nicht so komplett wieder okay ich mache
geld
[Musik]
ok also immer so ein bisschen in
concealer drauf
und dann wäre das so genannte mcqueen
ich mach keine kathrin spahn dapd dafür
entschuldige ich nicht jetzt
ich wollte eigentlich felix lob recht
tickets kriegen für heute die wir machen
sollen vor laufen aber ich glaube es
läuft jetzt schon aber wenn felix
prächtig verkauft die sind ja eher von
partikeln aus
schlimmer als bei wiki es mittlerweile
und der concealer wirkt jetzt wie so ein
so
ok
jetzt habe ich einfach mein finger in
das geld hinein
aber seht ihr den unterschied das geld
was da schon auch ein finger ist und das
was da jetzt sie genauer adamy es ist
halt nur in dieser puren konzentration
über mussten
ja ich mache es auf meine auge und ist
wird sofort
dieses neongelb verschnitt das habe ich
halt gelb und nicht hatte
ideen wie das feuer aussagen wie das
jetzt an meinem auge aussieht es ist
nicht mehr das gleiche geld und da kann
ich darauf machen wie ich möchte
das wird gleich wieder oder das ist hier
schon wieder so normal es gibt also
schon geil aus muss man einfach sagen
und wiedermal vanessa
agrana und professionell
die palette stuhl hinstellen lassen das
kann man schon echt coole sachen machen
ja doch noch nie
aber jetzt ist das ihr seht es ist gelb
das ist in gelb das ist nicht mehr
[Musik]
nicht so schön
kleiner paradiesvogel bin ich jetzt
aber es ist jetzt nicht mehr
ich könnte ich gehe noch mal die farbe
tritscher ein bergleute das ist glitzer
oder das paradies vogel cdu
jetzt seht ihr schaf das ist man die
farben leuchten so krass ist meine
kamera von ausrastet die sind regio
paradiesvogel
wenn eltern
haben
seid ihr eigentlich auch team
paradiesvogel oder er so natürliche töne
dass du kannst mir selber auch
weiß ich nicht irgendwie das gefühl dass
die farben immer kurz so poppig aussehen
wie sie aussehen sollen und dann
irgendwie im so was anderes wechseln
die zeit ist also von meiner haustür hör
ich schon die silvesterknaller
wenn es draußen dunkel man muss nicht
meter weit sehen diese leuchte wie sein
eigenes kleines feuerwerk winkend
aussehen
was von diesen weißen und das ist immer
schön hier eingeben
das gibt deinem auge ein effekt als ob
du noch am leben wäre und nicht schon
innerlich tot
ich bin team in die fresse make up a
half und meinte ich finde es schön dass
du immer so heftigen lidschatten trägst
kann nicht jeder und es steht ja ich
glaube es keinen viele leute ich glaube
viele leute die zum beispiel auch sich
mit menschen vergleichen sie sich gern
und viel schminke glauben wir euch viele
immer so dass sie nicht so gut aussehen
aber die wahrheit ist ja keine seele
nicht so gut aus außerdem wirklich
natürlichen schönheiten und da könnt ihr
mir noch so viel sagen dass ich ohne
make-up gut aus aber es ist eben wissen
wovon ich rede wenn ich meine so
natürliche schönheiten diese dauerhaft
außenbahnen lernen wurden na ja auf
jeden fall möchte ich sagen dass jeder
mit ein bisschen mühe und make-up halt
so richtig arm aussehen kann ab einem
gewissen alter
muss jetzt nicht glauben dass man sich
mit zwölf anfang muss jetzt hier im
kreis zu schminken weil das irgendwie
auch nicht erprobt
dafür hat man noch später genug zeit um
sich die haut damit zu werke
was sich dazu an ich denke dass ich das
anziehen aber jetzt irgendwie der
kommunikation sich aus also meine haare
nicht gemacht haben wirklich schlecht in
der kombination sich aus wikis bensmann
dort gefällt mir sehr gut
jetzt kommt aber der liegt und mit dem
verpacken wir sind alles was wir bis
jetzt gemacht haben
wartet noch abwartet bevor ihr eure
kommentare gibt jetzt kommt erstmal der
einheit
nee das ist echt cool aus ich sogar dass
das sieht es vielleicht krank aus in der
kamera
aber dieses
ich habe ihr können irgendwas sehen
warum muss man dabei den mund auf haben
das ist das für ein gesetz
boom
boksic auf das ist dann das auge sieht
jetzt voll so nackt aus
ja
ich weiß es bei jedem sommer bietet das
auge immer andere dann geht er mit einem
ganz anderen winkel ran
aber schießt reitet gern ich mein unser
körper ist eh nicht symmetrisch warum
sollte unser make-up symmetrisch sein
st
leider kann ich aber auch euch auf jeden
fall nicht empfehlen der sich gut
david slade my dial einer extreme
wenn man den mund dabei aufhält zwinkert
man nicht unwillkürlich und alles nur
weil man lidschatten drauf hat und kein
eyeliner keine wimpern gemalt immer ganz
gut ich mal die nämlich mal ein bisschen
schon an feucht wimpern aufkleber das
ist irgendwie gefühl dass man dann beim
wimpern draufkleben dass ich die windeln
da schon ein bisschen an den festtagen
können
ihr habt
schön
augen sind auch unterschiedlich lassen
wir jetzt mal nicht so streng
jetzt komme zudem wimpern das was alle
beauty star überspringen warum
verspringen sie wimpern anmalen weil es
zu lange gedauert weil dann erst mal so
liegt die wimpern und gesehen vielleicht
wieder wieso die augenbrauen und was
macht ihr da hinter der kamera
dass ihr das nicht zeigen wollte also
ich zeige euch das gerne bei mir
passiert
also dafür benutze ich mein anastacia
slogan beverly hills augenbrauen pampel
die schon mittlerweile nicht mehr so gut
aussieht bin ich ehrlich mit euch
während ringen fehlen
manchmal dann einfach
während jedoch nicht also geh nicht zu
hoch weil man sich extrem unnatürlich
aus
aber gerade so dass die oberen haare
mit einem braunen schatten untermalt
sind
und dann hier schön runter gehen dass
die vielleicht habe er sich auch mal
eine pochette fühlen
schön vorne
ein bisschen
nach vorne gehen
das der anfang nicht so hart ja und
somalia kommt man sie nicht mit den
linken ist schon anders und irgendwie
gewöhnt man sich so kraft daran dass man
ich könnte jetzt niemals mein make-up so
machen und meine augenbrauen einfach
klasse
wer bin ich ja auch schon so gestiegen
und schule und keine ahnung aber dieses
augenbrauen anmalen hat bei mir in
erster der zwölften klasse angefangen
dass wir dann plötzlich aus dem rossmann
so einem augenbrauenstift in der schule
hat nun dann die mädels ist alles so
verteilt haben und jeder immerhin der
pause versucht sich die augenbrauen
anzumalen ich kann mich nicht daran
erinnern und kamen wir alle aus der
pause und hatten alle so dicke
augenbrauen
ich meine man schon erwachsenen frauen
nicht sehen aber trotzdem war das
highlight wie tag und nacht
denn die eigentlich eure augenbrauen so
kann wie somalia klar kann sie ja dieses
kurve
weil die kleinen talente
für mich immer diese tickt ochs aufregen
die dann auch sagen so ich hab gehört
man kann nicht die luft anhalten und
dabei lächeln und dann macht man
natürlich
und dann sagt die person und schönes
lächeln durchschlagen
okay so nachdem ich meine oma 2100
zuschauer ich freue mich dass sie alle
da seid nachdem wir unsere augenbrauen
an gemalt haben benutze ich meistens
eigentlich immer seit drei jahren
ich glaube dieses ding hält schon seit
drei jahren ich kann es euch wärmstens
empfehlen weil ich das seit drei jahren
benutzen noch nie auf die idee gekommen
bin es zu wechseln
dann wirst dich und früher habe ich voll
vorsichtig gebürstet und hab so ein
bisschen aber mittlerweile greife ich da
richtig rein und ziehe die so groß dass
sie so richtig aussehen
ich glaube das habe ich nie von hp
abgeguckt
[Musik]
und dann hast du so ein
das sieht nicht gut aus
eigentlich crazies gefühl dass jedes
jahr ist immer etwas mit make up dazu
gekommen
da hat man angefangen sich die augen für
sich haben sich alle angemalt dann
highlight dann war jetzt die wimpern
ankleben ein muss dann ist man dauerhaft
verlängern irgendwohin muss dann kannst
du dir die wimbledons auch so unveiled
nun für längere zeit ist sie halt immer
so per maus sehen konnte ring kamen dazu
dass konnte jedes jahr
ich frag nicht welcher teufel da
irgendwo sitzt und sich jedes jahr
wieder was neues ausdenken
nächstes jahr werden die einen sich auch
die
[Musik]
make up kann auch ablaufen sagt halte
ich jetzt hier aber für ein gerücht
konnte man nur neun monate lang benutzen
nachdem man es auch gemacht hat ihr
könnt jetzt wahrscheinlich sehen aber
ich muss sagen ich habe noch keinen
augenbrauen ausschlag bekommt das heißt
benutzen die scheiße weiter und ich
glaube die machen das auch weil sie sich
bloß absichern wollen bei wenn du halt
etwas benutzt und dann zwei jahre
benutzt und es dann irgendwann sehr
schlecht geworden ist können die sagen
jaja aber wie gesagt nach neun monaten
wegschmeißen aber ist auch schon die
nach neun monaten
ich mach jetzt auch was ganz böse ist
mit einem concealer ziehe ich das so
also dann man hier den drauf und dann
noch so wie im übrigen die lidschatten
so ein bisschen wecken verschwinden
einfach da irgend also sieht man halt
nicht aber dann hast du halt eine
schönere linie
oder kommt er auf
und sowieso leute an silvester ganz
ehrlich als ob da irgendwer jetzt drauf
wie man konnte noch sind du bist
wunderschön dankeschön das ist sehr nett
sie bekommen in komplimente aber es ist
tritten schwer sie anzunehmen wenn wir
nimmt man nicht gerne komplimente ist
nichts neues wenn ich erzähle aber
trotzdem kann man noch mal drüber reden
so ich verstehe nicht warum da so ein
beauty felder also als ob meine haut so
aussehen würde dann gegen die webcam da
oben sieht das aber nicht gut aus das
ist das ist kein lidschatten das ist
meine natürliche das einfach der
schatten der aus dieser unfall bekommt
wenn ich das jetzt tun hat
angeben dass ich das machen kann kann
dein freund levy april empfehlen meinen
freund kann sehr die idee april
empfehlen und ich auch ich habe mir aber
ehrlich gesagt dass er die ganze zeit
schon zu wollen welche brille er benutzt
die oculus ruf als sie so von facebook
also facebook ist er prozent ich weiß
nicht ob also da steht ein facebook
drauf das hat mich überrascht ich dachte
mir ja okay wir müssen jetzt
ich habe vorher mache ich alles anderen
denn die will man nämlich drauf sind
dann habe ich dann so viel in der fresse
sollte ich meine wimpern auch jetzt
könnt ihr euch alle die das nicht
mitbekommen hier
das sind meine wimpern das sind die von
love mit der hat tisch mit kollektion
und ich habe mir so 5 also erstmal beim
einpacken geholt dann hatte ich die
wimpern auf instagram drauf nennen sind
die leute alle ausgerastet habe gesagt
oh mein gott vanessa du bist der
schönste mensch der welt mit diesen
scheiß wimpern und dann dachte ich so um
ich bin der schönste mensch der welt
damit nur bohlen wir mal fünf packungen
hier habe ich irgendwie acht euro kostet
48 euro für die 48
ja
58 48
fünf mal 36 5 x 7
nicht böse gemeint sondern eine normale
frage wieso schminkt man sich die augen
gelb orange oder schwarz weil das mega
spaß macht weil am anfang fühlt man sich
irgendwie komisch war das schon
ungewohnte anblick ist aber es macht
einfach tierisch spaß sich so bunt zu
schwinden
ich meine du musst ja mal vorstellen
leute in rio de janeiro mit ihrem
karneval wenn die da diese riesenfehler
kleider anziehen und diese riesen
glitzer hüte mit federn drauf und dieses
krasse make up kann man sich allerdings
warum mach dir das denn
und wenn ja auch seine leute weil es
spaß macht sich fliesen aufzukleben 40
ergibt
ach so und das ding ist
man muss immer erst mal dieses alte
wissen ab machen weil sonst sehen wir
irgendwann echt kacke aus und sie darauf
klebt
und dann mache ich immer so mit dem satz
ab sagt dann rolle ich die in der hand
hält er es wegen der diesen schönen
schwung haben und nicht komplett kaputt
da kann man wieder hatten sie darauf und
ich benutze eine packung ein paar
wimpern benutze ich extrem viel
also die heilige extrem lange 540 mal
ist das peinlich
die beste mathe arbeit und meine ganzen
schule geschrieben damals das werde ich
auch noch meinen enkelkindern erzählen
damals in der realschule beide
abschlussprüfungen habe ich die beste
selbst der junge der in unserer klasse
am besten macht mathe war der mag der
mag hat mit zwei gehabt und ich eine
eins da hat der markt das ist meine
schönste schule natürlich jetzt noch das
war abschlussprüfung für mathe ich
wusste man dass ich gute mathe bin aber
ich hatte war ein sehr faules kind und
hatte mit bock auf schule ich hatte mit
bock auf kunst und geschichte von der
einstigen zeche ich hab noch nie auf
kunst sprich geschichte studierte so als
ob jetzt ganz kurz ich nehme jetzt die
wimpern und das ist echt riesig
du machst ein auge zu das andere
natürlich auf lebten vor dran und da
seid nicht zimperlich damit sein weil
manche leute fahren behandeln diese
wimper als ob sie so wenn die nicht beim
ersten stück perfekt drauf legt sind na
ja auf jeden fall liegt wieder an
und dann musst du sie hin und herziehen
ein bisschen rum drücken bis sie dann so
liegt dass sie dir gefällt dann ab so
ran guckst ob sie überall sitzt guckst
ob sie nicht in die kurve ich auf deiner
dings liegt weil das könnte dir so ein
bisschen deine augen form verpacken
und dann wieder rauf
ich hätte sie jetzt ein bisschen weiter
vorne geklebt von scream abgelenkt
gewesen
einsendeschluss wenn er nicht so
naja zurück zur story und dann musste
ich für die abschlussprüfungen werden
weil ich hatte eine fünf in mathe ich
hätte eine fünf in mathe bekommen
es war wirklich nur ringscheibe ich war
aber auch im letzten jahres hat alles
andere mich also mich hat alles andere
mehr interessiert als in mathe wie jungs
zum beispiel fand ich viel interessanter
als mathe dann habe ich zwei wochen oder
drei wochen vor der abschlussprüfung
angefangen zu lernen weil ich wusste
wenn ich da eine fünf in mathe hat wird
es mir voll schwer fallen auf diese
andere schule zu kommen für die
fachhochschulreife pipapo in stade falls
ihr kinder aus stade seit juli stadel
geil junge mann schule auf jeden fall
brauche ich das dann und dann dachte ich
okay er in drei wochen ist mathe
abschlussprüfung man hat ja dann immer
schon ein bisschen weniger unterricht
und so was mal werden kann habe ich das
ein bisschen gelernt was ist das kind
was in mathe eine fünf
ich hab den abschlussprüfungen die
einzige 1 auf der ganzen schule und ich
also ich und ich habe gemerkt dass es
nicht wahr weil irgendwie weil ich
gerade das gelernt was vorkam oder
begnügen was es war einfach nur weil ich
einfach mal gelernt habe alles
verstanden habe und für mich das dann
einfach nur einfache rechnung waren die
ich dann kurz mal eben runter rechnen
also dass ich mal hin
dann hatte ich diesen auf also auch als
die arbeit eingeschrieben waren alle so
rauskamen meinen soko alter und das war
sooo schwer dachte ich man muss sie doch
einfach nur das anwenden was man gelernt
wird aber so hätte die ganze schulzeit
ablaufen können hätte ich mal gelernt
ich bin habe ich mehr
obwohl in der oberstufe muss man ja zum
glück ein bisschen mehr selbst denken
und nicht nur aus mich außer matte matte
wird immer so ein paar klicks sie auch
so ein bisschen von oben park ich diese
quasi ein als er sich festgebissen und
dann negiert dass sie zu viel da
passiert das jetzt hoch gegangen
aber da macht man sich jetzt keine
sorgen wenn man nimmt sie auch nicht
schlimm das war jetzt kleber ist weil er
wird durchsichtig trocknen müssen die
würfel du kannst du auch gerne kannst du
wenn wir noch mal abnehmen noch mal
komplett neu positionieren
die andere zu
alle guten dinge sind drei den rest des
abends die sie gerade so viel krasser
selbst ich glaube ich lass mir im neuen
jahr war echt mal so eine wimpern
verlängerung geben weil ich gefragt die
auch so gerne drauf das problem ist mein
moment verlängerung ich finde das super
ich finde man sieht danach immer so ein
bisschen aus wie ein gerupftes huhn wenn
man nicht regelmäßig geht im aufwind
es ist halt so teuer dass es weh tut
wenn man das macht weil es kostet ja so
100 euro die sie sich ein paar sind man
aufklären zu lassen
und ganz ehrlich wer hat 100 euro um
sich wimpern auch klassen das ist ein
richtiges commitment wenn du hundert
euro für wimpern aus liebst dann lebst
du das dann fühlst es so krass
das ist ein pinsel der ist eigentlich
für puder wir benutzen den auch für
controlling weil wir in unserem leben
nicht auf die reihe kriegen
das ist natürlich ein scherz ich bin
bombenbau die alle sind
jetzt kommen die gleichen krank kannst
du das empfehlen da ich nicht lange
dabei sein kann wünsche ich allen einen
guten rutsch gut denn roger kleine käfer
ein funky king of queens über alles es
ist schon 15 42 gastspiel schon wieder
sind es die berlin oder berlin die
berlin sind nicht so ganz krass wie die
istanbul oder ich habe mir auch extra
die berlin geholt bei den nicht so krass
sind und dann habe ich das erst mal
drauf und bin so richtig überrascht weil
so krass ist so ein bisschen controlling
dann machen wir auch keine wissenschaft
daraus sowieso ein bisschen beide fahren
man die dritte und dann entscheidet sich
meine kamera wieder zum komplex über
lichten
ich habe manchmal das gefühl wenn man
sie schminkt videos auf youtube sie
haben es 100 millionen sachen falsch
machen kann
ich glaube war ein also oder oder so
richtig machen musst ich glaube aber
einfach wenn man genug mut hat einfach
drauf los zu legen merkt man viele wege
führen nach rom
auch wenn ich nicht im richtigen pinsel
und so benutze zum controlling dass also
das ist beim schminken scheißegal
und jetzt ist mein kopf konturiert den
man eh nicht sehen wird weil ich ein
pony hat und man erkannte um die
weihnachtsgans wieder weg zu machen
die widmen aber nie ganz weg machen
so konkurriert ist dann nämlich nochmal
meine wimpern scheiße weil wir machen
wir nochmal ganz findet ganz unangenehm
nah dran
ja ich mache mein schönes land
das hilft so ein bisschen den bann zieht
man sieht es ja aus so ein gefährt
wir sind jetzt also wie vor die großen
augen hätte komisch seht ihr das wie
meine augen also machten wir machen
maria fe damit zum beispiel ließ wieder
für hin- und hergeht aber sowieso
kameralinsen er so barbara banga was man
nicht wann ich bin 26
ich bin so cool dass du dich einfach
schminkt wie du bock hast und keine
wissenschaft daraus machst sieht auch
extrem basta dankeschön
ja ich glaube das ist so gerade man
braucht für viele sachen braucht man
kein talent braucht man immer auch so
ein bisschen mut wenn auch der mut fehlt
dann wirst du natürlich kein ergebnis
erzielen wenn man braucht für sachen
mode einfach rein da machen wie man
glaubt nicht irgendwie denken weil es
irgendwie so ein richtigen weg gibt es
gibt ja auch eigentlich den weg wie man
nach der schule weitermachen soll aber
trotzdem durchführen millionen menschen
ihre nester surfen gehen für ein jahr
eine surfschule aufmachen aus dieser
surfschule wird ein label dann machen
sie eine surf klamotten reihe und wird
sie sind sie millionäre und die haben
nichts von ihnen sich gegen weg nummer
ich weiß nicht wie ich gerade auf diese
surfer gekommen bin aber ich finde sie
super so das ist mein sohn lippen
dann gab seinem comeback bin ich ehrlich
mit euch kreolen theaterschminke auf
jeden fall ist das so eine fahne nicht
funktioniert und zu allem weil dieser
name lippenfarbe ist bei dem muss man
auch extrem aufpassen
am anfang extrem geil
dani ist super mann
und ich mache
immer wenn ich mich über meinen lippen
und das ist auf einer seite passiert und
probieren war so gut dass gleich auf der
anderen seite wünschen wir uns weg zu
machen
und ich kann mich auch nie entscheiden
ob ich diese linie auf dieser lippe auch
an mahle oder nicht
das sieht auch gerade echt nicht
definitiv an mir irgendwas anderes
gerade wieder die schuld bei der
gesichtsbehandlung ansuchen aber doch
dass das liegt weder von meiner haut
letzten der haut wie sieht aus als ob du
ja stellt sich die frage entweder darm
bad oder halt scheiße und hier sowieso
das ist auch sondern komme ich nicht
überwunden ist die schuld von nicht
beklagen
ok highlight was sagt ihr dazu
highlighter du könntest einen
bräunlichen lippenstift oder etwas in
richtung rosenholz defekten der
harmonisches bild und konnten jetzt
super zusammen und am ende muss man wie
auch sein was sieht man dann eigentlich
wenn man draußen steht so erstmal
du straße grab meines boutiquen gebieten
so viele leute an der via brille
russland jetzt habe ich hier auch noch
so ein bisschen wie haben
wie viel farbe du benutzen seien positiv
[Musik]
so
und jetzt auch noch highlighter drin war
jetzt auch noch
warum
aber wie gesagt das ist am ende auch
signal weil ja auch keiner drauf achtet
neue die menschheit beachtet euch nicht
nur zu so weit wie du sie beachtet was
rede ich dass ich da jetzt wollte ich
versuchen das war's jetzt muss mir nur
noch die haare machen
also ich finde das perfekt
ich weiß nicht wisst ja ich glaube am
besten einfach meine haare jetzt wir
machen das jetzt einfach spontan wir
müssen da jetzt auch nicht viel
während der jogger schon britney spears
modus gerade
ok
das ist es ich werde mich selbst und
meine haare nicht
es geht ja erinnerung mein gesicht die
schöne neue ausbilder sehen wir mal
den muss ich halt raus war zumal das
gerät gut das tut noch zu gut dass
celtic pony also leute dort ist sie doch
jude aus so kann ich gehen haben weil
sie noch nicht vielleicht sehe ich auch
so neongelben pulli an damit man so in
der mut bleibt
und die bringen ja ok aber der
lippenstift dieses hier ist nun voll
die professionelle weg macht technik
weil das leben sagt oh mein gott das
lied verpackt
schon besser
die haare so den ersten wieder so ja
weil wenn man rausgeht das gleiche
könntest meine haut tu berlin mit
reisetipps machen das würde ich 2020 zu
gern hätte so lust auf so ein format wo
ich so auch restaurants einfach
ausprobieren und dann zu lassen die
besten rahmen in berlin essen oder das
teuerste 1 oder die besten aus daun weil
ich ja auch aus seiner liebe hmm ja ich
werde das passt schon wann es ein paar
schon jacky keiner mehr warum ich meine
haare die das ist doch verachtet keiner
drauf man muss es eben geht nicht immer
so fertig machen dass man mit sich
selbst zufrieden sind so aus der
hausgemeinschaft beim anbau nie glauben
dass irgendwem auffällt was man macht ja
auch schon geil wenn wenn frauen so
sauer sind wenn die vom friseur
obwohl es nicht immer so könnt ihr gar
nicht auf dass dies niemand aufhält wenn
du was verändert bedeutet ja nur dass du
alles machen kannst und ist kein jux
glitzer fehlt noch einmal mit blick auf
die wange übertreibe ich auch machen sie
aus als ob ich wieder auf dem karneval
der kulturen möchte oder so viel spaß
guten rutsch und chrysler an babsi und
babsi las ich heute wieder zu hause habe
sie kann ich mitkommen ich möchte
nämlich am ersten ersten ich habe mir
ganz fest vorgenommen ich möchte morgen
aufstehen so um 12 uhr
11 12 uhr und ich möchte aufstehen ich
möchte das frühstücken ich möchte meine
koreanische serien machen wie ich gerade
wieder angefangen habt cinderella in the
flight absolute empfehlung es ist so gut
dass sie immer wieder irgendwo eine neue
serie haben ich denke so etwas habe ich
noch nie gesehen
nein absolut nicht es gibt noch eine
million andere sieht man sich auf jeden
fall auch anschauen soll so kannst du
den dankeschön so lustigen wir jetzt an
den anfang des streams guckt man das ist
doch echt das ist doch einfach wohl
jeder kann bombastisch aussehen
mithalten weiß nicht ob es oberflächlich
klingt aber jeder kanal gut richtig gut
aussehen und make up um seinen bock
daran zu haben
und ich finde das macht halt so was fürs
selbstbewusstsein geht man halt raus und
man fühlt sich halt so wie man aussieht
und ja und kann also das ist
oberflächlich um das ist von
irgendwelchen magazin magazine leben ein
das vor dass man jung auszusehen hat und
das ist auch blöd aber ändert ja nichts
an der sache ist dass gut fühlen ist
dann machst du wieder in mode man leute
2020 nächstes jahr
[Musik]
ich mag schon das gefühl weil manche
sagen okay
doch nichts vor weil wenn man wirklich
einhalten
aber ich mag dieses gefühl von
ich mag dieses gefühl von neustadt jetzt
kann man es man kann ja jeden tag sein
leben verändern aber bei sylvester hat
man so richtigen wie so ein schubser
kriegt man da und da hat man die chance
wirklich etwas zu verändern und zu sagen
im nächsten jahr reicht's mehr ich
möchte das anders machen und ich möchte
das schöner machen ich möchte das raus
aus meinem leben habe ich möchte das
sind typen und das wünsche ich euch
allen dass sie irgendetwas erreicht im
nächsten jahr oder das ihr euch ein
vorsatz macht linie ein haltet oder
einfach einfach weiter glücklich sein
ball etwas anstrebt das beste leben zu
führen was ihr aus eurem leben raus
holen könnt ja das ist mein gut ich kann
diesen eyeliner strich nicht ich muss
aber auch was sagen das ist alles was
ich mache diesen eyeliner strich man
jetzt schon seit fast zehn jahren
und deswegen muss dabei mir schon so
aussehen weil wenn ich nach zehn jahren
immer noch hier sitzen würde und sagen
okay jetzt wegen beleidigung der 13 ja
auch noch nicht kann aber ich mache seit
zehn jahren regelmäßig fast täglich
kleiner springen das meine ich man darf
dabei nicht aufgeben so es gibt nichts
auf der welt außerdem pflegt man singen
oder so was man natural born einfach
kann hab nur wegen canyon die
entwicklung mit sorge
ich bin ich nicht mehr einkriegen
serienjunkie abo besitzt gerade hier in
kurzen stream das ist auch gut so leute
macht euch fertig macht euch hübsch
kennt euch eure haare geht unter die
dusche falls sie das machen müsst
genießt den heutigen abend wenn ihr
alleine zu hause seit dann macht etwas
was euch gefällt weil ganz ehrlich am
ende gebraucht niemanden um euch gut zu
fühlen wenn ihr nur euch selber gerade
hat das wird sich ändern wenn ihr
unzufrieden damit sei das sie gerade nur
ich selber hab dann bedeutet das dass
ihr daran arbeiten müsst und dafür
sorgen müsse dass sich diese situation
ändert so schön gesagt aber sie sagen
möchte es mit euch selber auch so
glücklich und zufrieden sein
und da reicht es nicht zu sagen na ja
aber ich mag mich nicht
na dann ändert das so
raucher kann ja auch sagen ja aber ich
also ich kann nicht aufhören
doch kann er jeder wir können immer
jeden tag mit dem aufhören was uns nicht
gut und wenn ihr sagt dieser hand von
timo glock
alles gute ich war nun gerade so einen
gibt
ich wünsche euch auf jeden fall
spielspaß
glaubt an euch believe in you save your
self bts lila herz was gibt es noch was
ist aufwendigen so findigen das ist das
ding
beauty ich sag dann tschüss ich wünsche
euch einen guten rutsch rutscht gesund
rein passt auf euch auf wenn ihr alkohol
trinkt wirklich passt doch ich auf kann
eure grenzen und passt auf eure freunde
auf hat sie mit den unterwegs seid
schaut dass ihr alle zusammen bleibt und
ihr die übersicht habt und dann würde
ich sagen
bis zum nächsten mal ach so und dann
will ich sagen bis nächstes jahr leute
wir sehen uns erst nächstes jahr wieder
ich habe keine zeit dazwischen
nächstes jahr soll es dann aufs knie
ich kann mich so schwer von euch trennen
aber ich liebe das nächstes jahr